all right hello everyone
and welcome to this one
um here I'm going to talk about
um a couple of my games
we're going to focus on them
um
yeah so some are tricky I'm gonna start
with this one
um I played soupy
I don't think you all know him but you
may as well guess where he's from that's
you know that's a good Head Start also
meanwhile let me try to find Snoopy
soupy
Oh wrong one wrong one no no no get out
we get out of there
was it this one no
okay okay this one yay we found it
somehow someway we managed to find it
yay
that's cheating no no you don't get
extra information you uh
nickname like he plays like soup soupy
maybe I don't know you still have to
guess which country it is
okay
it's fair that's fair
enough
too so I guess I'm not gonna go country
I'll go with Thailand you know what I
have a better guess he's from her okay
so soupy
is from Brazil
so um
all right seven to E4
E6
4d5 E5 now this one's somewhat strange
right you look at it and it's like yes
what is this
what exactly is this
so if you look at it
what are your first thoughts like what
could be the positive
of these moves thank you
and what could be the downside
I'm really strangling like the
development of where the black pieces
can go
on the way so you're really
really but then like also I guess the
negatives are you're like cramping in
probably your Bishops that you know
because it looks like you're gonna be a
cramped game and you're like so you're
yeah but the good thing about Chess
that you sort of
tied together with your opponent if it's
gonna be rough it's going to be rough
for it together yeah yeah you're gonna
suffer together it's not no it's nothing
like I'm not gonna you're be the one
suffering we're gonna take a look at
that game if we have the time
where it's only one side that really
suffers
but yeah that that's kind of like these
positions
it's closed it's very difficult to move
around
so this side is this this is me that is
that guy okay so when did when did you
play a floor did you play you played E4
when you put and you played that four
next like yeah
it's all legal whatever you see here it
happened
it happened so uh
it actually can occur
yeah
yeah it's yeah no no but this is a
different opening okay was black then
pushed upon so we talked about the fact
that there is a positive we've got a
pawn here and we take away the F6 Square
but what could be the downside
of um
of these moves
exactly so there is this Death Valley of
chess
if I borrow a term
the king can get
easily attacked on this side of the
board because the f-bond has been pushed
already right
and it's not that terrible you're right
because check and we can still block
or you put the knife on uh F3 take away
that square or like if he's too late to
get there yes it's fine but
um I mean there are the ups and there
are the downs and in fact even this
diagonal can be a little annoying as
we'll see in the game
C5 logical okay
so I assume most of you haven't really
seen this
type of position that's normal what do
you think should be our second step
gear
also of course as per usual the bishop
over that square ain't the greatest but
hey that's that's something that
you know you always
um suffer with if you play the French
the bad Bishop
okay
or I'm going to develop the
B
with check you know and
so I just said that this bishop on C8 is
terrible so if I go here I'm basically
being a friend to my opponent
we are not
friend of our opponent we're
Frenemies
we don't go here because we trade off
that terrible Bishop
or night after even
Okay so
you can always make moves but if you
don't know why you make the moves that
kind of defeats the purpose
okay so go on and tell me go on and tell
me
yeah so but every move you make isn't
always just defensive there are all
those principles you want to follow
yeah yeah
the castle have that rubber on that open
file and like start like I want to
Checkmate my opponent like I get it but
it's at the moment it's closed so yes we
dream we dream a lot but it's at the
moment it's still closed okay well you
you I know you're a grand manager so you
have a better plan than me no no I did
not say no no no the thing is
I'm okay with dreams but facts be facts
this is not an open file
you might have development
then I'm quicker than getting that done
no no that's that's correct if you're
yeah that way you're right
uh-huh
so I'm trying to develop like I said no
no you're doing the right thing I love
that argument there
okay
yeah so
um but as I told you like yep you would
be you'd be right but yeah we get it
yeah no no you are on the right track I
did go here I'm just saying like boat
race it's both race I'm like very much
about yeah forcing moves and like not
giving my opponent a chance to just
develop yeah
I want them to have to respond to what I
do yeah hey supper
um the thing is we also could play for
c3d4n I will
um in this game
hello as well so welcome chatterino
too
person people
um so Knight C6 that's okay
C3
so we're preparing this D4 break
oh it's I don't even know why I would
call it a break
uh it's more of like a solid structure
break I yeah that's kind of pushing it
so okay so
it's one thing
um to you know just play straightforward
side start to play a little bit more
convoluted
um if you think about it which one of
black species seem a little bit passive
right now
yes just a little just a little bit
passive I mean it could be a lot if you
feel like it that's fine too
um
I don't know these pieces are doing much
like the knights can't really go
anywhere and the Bishops can't go
anywhere really so they're all locked up
I mean that's kind of the reason I want
to go for D4 so my Bishop isn't gonna
get mummified over there
like this fella
hello sugar
now the night is one of those things
Knight A3 so this this if you'd say whoa
what is this move
you'd be correct whoa what the heck is
this move
now
chess is all about the center squares
yes
yes okay so we've
we've got a yes we've got a yes that's
good
where is this night-headed that's the
question
yeah so while the Knight isn't gonna
specifically go to D4 but it's gonna
control the all-important D4 Square yeah
yeah I get it
so gets the Knight over there
just to support that so Knight F5 Bishop
D3 again very strange looking move but
I'm just trying to get rid of the Knight
now don't forget
this is just a close position
now values change in closed positions
right
yes
that's it yes and let me move on that
that sounds like math class is that the
solution yes yes yes
was that the one that's the way you
solved your pro yes yes for sure then
look up the end no yes yes
they're mostly defensive pieces yeah the
bishop on C8 is super sad over there
uh can do nothing
it's pretty bad
and
once I snatch that horsey
I will have more nights
well
so of course there are like basic tenets
of Chess that you follow but it doesn't
mean if I just hit all the marks I win
the game sometimes you can do but most
of the times it's complicated
because like that's what I'm asking no I
don't disparage my opponent first of all
second of all second of all
second of all
if we think that a position is bad
that does not necessarily mean that the
position is bad it's maybe that we just
don't understand it
um the thing like you make sense what
you're saying but you're kind of maybe a
bit more used to open positions I have
that feeling but I might be wrong
um in this position
black actually doesn't have to get all
of his hair pieces out in General yet
because there's no way for me to attack
it
um it will take one two three more moves
to kind of complete development
yeah so just calmly getting all those
pieces out uh there's no need there's no
immediate rush to safety uh
oh yes over the closed position
it's sort of like
it's kind of like
imagining how time slows down
everything becomes very slow
everything in here just slowly starts to
unravel
um it's not gonna be that fast-paced
when you're playing this you weren't
thinking you're like
you're like
that wasn't needed
C4 took here
Knight C2 now I would have gone here any
case
but there is also this uh threat of
takings of castles they're gonna snip
this down and
this is actually one of the dangers in
these positions that you're left with a
terrible Bishop
so yeah uh indeed you've got in-person
people in here you should be here
instead of on Twitch what you doing
come over
anyways that's one of the reasons
I move the Knight of course I want to
control that square
so well in chess you have objectives so
that's why I wouldn't really be like
okay I'm just gonna Crush my opponent
because if you can uh actually achieve
your goals then good things happen but
if you don't hit your objectives that's
how your position deteriorates
probably okay
tonight's C2 and like here again it's
most of like a compliment for the
opponent
um the opponent realized huh
huh
I think I got what you're trying to do
so if black goes here
I will of course wall this up if the
bishop moves away well he's just got bad
Bishops and I got a beautiful Center
if they take
Queen takes castles here I've got a very
good move and
I think that my assessment sort of is
aligned with my opponents after the next
move which you guys will try to find why
it is pretty comfortable
yeah
um
it always sort of starts out of what we
cannot do
it's not just making a move before you
know it kind of like an instinctual move
just chasing the bishop yeah you chase
the bishop but does that achieve a whole
lot not really
um and what could be the upside of this
move
come on in
they want to they can come on in
so Bishop E3
um
the point is twofold one of them is
trade is good for me
because
this competing Bishop
is no longer around
and the key Square on D4 is under my
control
all of these positions
uh all these French positions whoever
controls these pivotal squares dominates
the game here I have an Undisputed
Advantage you have your sad bishop and I
got my happy Knight
that I enjoy with great Delight
that's kind of nice
so my opponent of course
does not want any of that because
realizes that strategically that must be
very much in my favor
so it does something that's typical play
but I mean you have to have a little bit
of an expert tree to find it we kind of
talked about the fact that this bishop
on C8 is
pretty bad
how could that Bishop on C8 markedly be
improved
so the thing is you do this
here you get ready for pushing the pawn
and I say
you ain't getting there
I stopped you in your tracks you are
still chilling with a terrible Bishop
just want to go back real quick why
don't you go ahead
yeah but that well first off you're
going backwards second of all
so even if you chase the queen which as
I said okay you chase my queen
that's true that's true you improve yes
yes
you improve the bishop however
you lost the fight for the D4 Square
okay all right that's fine that's fine
that's fine I understand you can be
contentious that's okay
I'm okay with that
however you lost your fight with over
the D4 Square
you managed to improve so chess is not
about 50 50.
it is a winner takes all game right
there is no such thing as I lose the
game and I still get something no you
lost it all
thank you
so that's what I'm saying
so
it's a vendor takes all game
you don't want to say okay I got my
Bishop but they got the center it's okay
for a while but that's not the goal
can you control the D4 square with the
bishop no you can because it's a wide
squared Bishop
that's not even something to be
considered and you can't count on that
either so you're saying they're like I
don't want to put put them in the center
just to have this my Bishop be you know
you you can and sometimes they do make
these trade-offs so what you're
suggesting and maybe I didn't phrase it
correctly or precisely enough
what you're doing you're you know give
and take that's what you said
they do that a lot of times but in an
ideal Universe you're trying to have it
all and you want it now
so he goes to D4
so
um he's basically kind of doing what
you're saying but says well it's going
to be worth the pawn and my Bishop that
used to be terrible isn't that terrible
anymore still garbage but it's still not
as bad as it could be
all right so my opponent offers me a
pawn what do we do
yeah we say thank you
my opponent offers me another Palm what
do we do
thank you yeah we take another Pawn now
there is going to be an upside and I
know it might seem that okay soupy isn't
knowing what he's doing but he he has
some vague idea like he is a very strong
Grandmaster so here
we don't trade we take there
take take now
we talked about one upside
for soupy for his decision but what is
the other upside
why giving up all these spawns Isn't So
tragic in this specific case
yes the soupy gets a lot of activity for
uh the two extra pawns what else there
is like a critical one that makes it all
legitimate and like sound that's what
I'm trying to say like the idea of what
he's playing for is not flawed and not
dubious
you have a bad Bishop
no
let's keep the integrity and let's keep
the love for our Bishop no hate on our
Bishops please
um kind of but the thing is mostly
is that we've got these colored Bishops
what's the difference between those
Bishops
yeah
but this is not an end game
exactly good point good point
don't say oh I can say oh you say the
answer
you get it wrong chat you don't say oh
I mean you can it's okay it's a free
world
um so yeah indeed
oh
the bishop is getting on the dieage
and my Bishop ain't that good
so B5 Queen D3 now I got and I can claim
a little bit of an advantage because
I've got the Pawns
Bishop here
okay
so we know the reasons why we are so
very sad
you don't want to stay sad forever
too too long
you can be sad sometimes but you can't
stay sad forever
you know soupy was sad with a French
Bishop now this is an honorary Karo Khan
Bishop
foreign
yeah
all right Chad is is on the roll
no
no casting is not bad uh but that's not
our reason for our grief
you're sad for other reasons
we are unconsolable that's how we said
we are
at the moment but sometimes a couple of
moves
prophylaxis is correct
okay
so maybe like
we're sad because of our bad Vision so
yes
correct
you want to get this bishop out so this
bishop actually becomes good
castles it's a little bit probably
not that accurate because I was like
haha castles now here haha I get my
Bishop out the tempo exactly and that's
actually something that's important
now my point is like I'm going to be the
one attacking you
and I was I'm going to be the one
counting the pawns
and there'd always be two more
and that scared him
okay now when your opponent is going to
attack you
naturally there's something you should
be looking for and you should stop what
should we stop in that case
of course
but I don't see no check here
now none of those matter I mean that's
the that's actually still the funny
thing checks capture Forks they don't
matter only
just the immediate idea how they can
attack your pieces that matter
so all this streamer nonsense forget it
it's there to hinder you
relearn this game you learn it all wrong
all wrong
you're a queen
it's still valuable
that was correct
they don't get everything wrong
they're not that bad
on the second ring yeah they'd be mean
like that so
ain't that disgusting they want to get
in so
please yeah
no
yeah yeah
yeah so I could go here but I don't want
to trade
um just gonna say lock it
lock it up so that row cannot come on in
there so it's beautiful Bishop C5 you
can come on in
now
this was one plan that we've been
talking about
but
black has another one
another one
yeah yeah he's gonna
no
probably not that yeah
yeah
so bringing the rook in here while you
all in-person people think
it's not necessarily bad but Bishops of
opposite colors are
so we want to win the game so no Rook C1
for you soupy Bishop C5
so drop no no draw no
E6
okay so those two moves together don't
make any sense
what if like he goes uh
G4 in the future and maybe and maybe
like uh I might have to move it on
or like
okay so
um
what streamers again forget to do
is mentioned that you don't push Pawns
in front of your own King
if you don't have to
if you have to you have to as you'll see
but you don't do it like hey I can push
this Pawn in front of my own King
isn't that a splendid idea now that
would be a Sound Advice they don't give
that that'd be too sound
so here that's not something black would
be scared of
e uh six
and then slide that over in front of the
king
yeah but where do you want to slide on
over with that Rook
ah G6 uh-huh
the queen would just jump right on over
that pond and an ear Queen would just
disappear and we would just have a
checkmating for it yeah yeah so that's
actually the upside of having an attack
with the opposite colored Bishops you're
practically down a piece
when we're sort of considering the fans
um
now
uh Cube you are not wrong in the sense
that you know this does not mean that oh
we lose the game you you win but it is a
threat
and he does go there
you guys are playing good or at least as
well as soupy so the three
Bishop D5 now there's two ways of sort
of trying to stop this idea two ways
and
two ways one of them is more humble and
the other one is less so
but I want to hear which one you guys
consider
I guess there's a third way but I kind
of considered the same exact thing but
we'll get there when you guys get there
better with folks no more folks here the
better you come here
yeah good all right
G3 then we establish a new you know
barrier and like basically his Bishop's
doing that yeah now of course if you
want to lose quickly we just throw Pawns
in front of our Kings that's perfect
yeah
because our Roots could just come up and
protect the new barrier that we created
like how's it going to get in
no so there's no such thing as a force
field in chess no such thing as a
barrier unfortunately
I guess what I'm saying is like if all
our pawns are on dark squares we know
the only thing getting in there is the
light Square bishop and like so unless
that Queen is helping it I don't see how
if if our if we're on the dark square
that Rook is going to be helping so now
he doesn't have anything you need help
to download her checkmates you can't
just do it with one piece so if we
reestablish those pawns on the dark
squares we're taking out any help other
than the queen with that Vision so then
what are we afraid of okay so we have to
make moves it's one thing it's one thing
to have no no okay
I said B3 oh H for G3 I thought you said
the G4 my bad no no I apologize
I misheard I thought you said G4
now
age four here I was mostly considering
this which I didn't play
here here
this was one idea let me finish this uh
thought process
you're good the bishop over here is
still kind of mounting pressure and
there's actually a very fine reason why
this is not that great for white black
here has a very very nice little well I
don't know if you could call it a
maneuver but a plan rather
which would sort of fix these folks on
the wide squares and that is not at all
ideal
so what could that be
and you'll be pretty pumped to hear what
I played actually because it's not far
off to what you were thinking
not exactly and I'll explain why but uh
but close
yes H5
H4 and this is pain why because then
this Pawn on G2 is eternally a Target in
this position and you can't really move
the pawn because there's just too much
power on that square
this would be pretty Pleasant for my
opponent so I decided to do something
that looks really strange however it's a
closed position
so I can get away with some things King
F2
any normal circumstance
you'd be
just kind of violating all the rules
but it's a closed position I dominate
the center
you can't do nothing to me nothing look
at stare at my two extra pawns you can't
do nothing
so Rook H6
H3
Rook G6 Rook G1 H5 do we tolerate H4
do we tolerate H4 chat
Tracy is shaking her head you guys are
saying nothing come on
no
what is this soft nose in the chat
hard G3 nerve no
you shall not pass
get out of here
now you might be wondering Okay so
what was the big deal the big deal is
you can get close to my king
also I really still want a bit of
flexibility so the difference between
the way I play and you
is that I just give myself this extra
option
I could push the pawn later if I want to
but I don't necessarily want to give
away
you know this white square on G4 so
that's why I go H3 and G3
okay
C6 Queen E2 and I'm asking some
questions my point is like ha I'm
weakening your king
I'm going like
what did I say
what it say to the dude
it's like huh give me the open file and
also thanks for the pawn
we open up the file in the Hunter
gets Hunted
because now we've got what we wanted
the open file
yes that's what we want rookie six H5
get out of here we need the open file
it's gonna be mad
yes
I disagreed but uh there's no take back
um I don't know why he played that move
what are the problems with chess is that
you can't argue with your opponent that
maybe you shouldn't
there is time but
I mean
the only time I heard this is when a
legendary player that is Victor korchnoy
um
he was having a winning position
and uh he whispered to his opponent
isn't it time you resign
and I'm not sure if that had the
profound effect but he did win the game
so rookie 6 H5 say get out of here here
okay so the Rook moved now what we do
because we are actually getting close to
our final touches
this position
because we don't want to draw
no well so
um that's sort of a bit of a
generalization
but there is a hint of truth to it you
start trading trading in the end what do
you expect it's going to be a drop
yeah we go Rook G5 we go on the double
and the funny thing is and that's why
it's good to capture pawns you can use
them as shelter the king can walk away
so this looks like scary but it's scary
on the surface but really it should make
you too nervous
thank you
here I take upon when I see one
here I bring my queen
G6 okay so I know how many extra pawns
we have right now I kind of lost count
four yeah a ton
so if you got a ton of Pawns you know as
much as a whale wait
come on what are you supposed to do
um yeah but we can't quite push it yet
you know there is like a technical thing
you can do
trade you trade
you trade so I went here and I was like
graciously offering my opponents to have
an ending where he's four pawns down
and I felt like okay my chances are
pretty good
opponent played here and then I was like
ah
maybe we'll find mate and there is one
so let's just find the mate and then
that will conclude our session
F5 Emon is a palm push but is neither a
check nor does it facilitate checkmate
okay that's a check I shall move my king
yep
so shame on the chat in person chat wins
see the winners celebrating righteously
and rightfully check
Queen f8
you got maimed chat that means you're
done
that means the chess club wins
thank you all
for attending thank you for being here
she is going to peruse your games
and it's gonna be fun
so don't miss it meanwhile I'll say
thank you and thank you for being here
and I wish you all the best
foreign